have you seen what Melania Trump just
said what uh Melania Trump just recently
said she would like uh she thinks Tucker
would be a great vice president
candidate where did that come from like
where did that where does that come out
of the blue like when have you ever
heard an ex president's wife going you
know what I like that guy to be the vice
president that means she probably heard
something what you mean it came out of
that blue right there yeah yeah exactly
you know she heard something come on
come on she heard something and went I
like them you know when's the first time
anybody said anything about Tucker being
a VP it was on this podcast I wait let
me guess it was called the alliance
between Elon Tucker and Trump and by the
way you know what just came up about
Tucker did you hear the story about what
the negotiation was why he went on X
watch this year uh this is the story Rob
do you have that or
no on on uh Tucker going uh starting his
media company and what he got with
Twitter and exchange is that the one is
that the one that says all right let me
see if it's in there or not if not you
can pull it up I'll show you the article
as well
and I talked about this a couple of a
months ago so here we go Tucker Carlson
New Media Company moves forward I think
they raised 15 million bucks a couple
months ago um we are opened our site for
membership sales subscribers will gain
access to exclusive content and behind
the scenes footage although pricing
details remain on the schools Patel
mentioned that the official launch will
once will follow once you know despite
this depart Tucker okay go type in
Tucker is this the one that says 50 so
he went on Twitter XS to do his show in
exchange for 50 retweets with
Elon what yes that's all he needed in
exchange for 50 retweets with Elon so if
you type in Tucker Carlson x uh 50
retweets retweets that's so that's so
weird that's so like but but it's this
is exactly what I talked about when I
said why would Tucker turn down the100
million offer we made to him because 50
retweets from Elon is worth more to him
than $100 million think about that 50
retweets is worth more than $100 million
offer being made and was it was it any
specific or whenever just I mean not
back to back to back to back to back or
whenever Tucker goes please retweet this
one what do you mean like which which
tweets of Tucker were I have to show you
guys this because you have to see it you
have to it to understand what I'm
talking about uh with with him and musk
but the idea is now Melania is saying
hey maybe this guy would make a good VP
um you know he you know she would like
to see him be a VP and potential
candidate as a VP do can you see Tucker
as a VP Tom do you think that would be a
wise move to have Tucker Carlson as the
VP for Trump absolutely tell me why well
number one this guy is very well read
and not only that his position
statements and his point of views on the
three key areas that a president really
can impact he can impact the economy
through treasury number one number two
he can uh impact domestic policy through
things that he puts out there like a
Disaster Area recovery things like that
then also on foreign policy whose
secretary of state is in the positions
that we take on the two things in
foreign policy defense-oriented
positions where like you're giving guns
to a friend
um or or economics and those are the
things that I think Tucker Carlson
really has a very strong intellect on
and he understands how Washington works
so if if that's the measure of a vice
president understanding how Economic
Policy um and then domestic policy in
general and foreign policy work then the
guy the guy has the the credentials to
be there and he's very visible to the
American voters so now let's go the
other way you know you got to pick
somebody who's visible you got to Pi
somebody who's bankable votable
electable and he has all those so if I
look at it on a quantitative basis that
way you know the the old method was hey
you're not very strong in Texas maybe
LBJ could be your vice president
candidate and help you carry Texas that
used to be the way it works it doesn't
really work that way anymore it's all
about the candidate but the vice
president can't be a drag um we all know
who the vice president candidate was for
John McCain and she was a drag on the
ticket you don't want that Dan Quail
even though he proved to be right in
Vanity Fair wrote an article that said
Dan Quail was right about the following
things he was a
drag on on Bush Senor so you can't be a
drag on the ticket you have to be
something and they the last time you've
seen um I think
something well let's go look at Obama
and Biden Biden was the Elder Statesman
that knew his way around Washington so
you can trust that Obama's going to get
good advice that was the pitch that we
were all sold on the selection of uh Joe
Biden and I think Tucker lines up very
well he checks all the boxes he'd be a
ferocious debater and so I think then
you have to think okay one heartbeat
from the presidency okay could he be you
know a president on the order of Reagan
EST uh conservatism that is that is uh
been successfully malleable into the
world in which we live today and I think
the answer is yes I think I dude like
imagine having him as Vice he wouldn't
be one of these Kamala do nothing just
by the way don't even know what what
Kamala does or where she is he'd be a
phenomenal vice president and then think
like you said Tom he' take the mantle I
think because I think he's a true
patriot and then you never know maybe
he'd put like a VC or somebody as his
vice president then that that line of
just true people that care about this
country will keep keep keep on going and
I think that that be a great choice I
would love I would love I don't see it
guys what I don't see it you don't see
what U I don't I don't I think Tucker is
an alpha I don't think he's trying to
take advice from like listen to anybody
be number two for anybody he walked into
the UFC behind Trump and looked like a
pretty good number two I just I think
Tucker is focused on building his Media
company he's never ran for anything in
his life he's never expressed any
interest for running anything in his
life and if I'm Trump I want someone
that's basically saying get behind me
have my back basically do what Mike
Pence did for 3 years and 364 days okay
and just follow my lead and also I don't
see Tucker bringing any independent or
votes that Trump doesn't already have
people that like Tucker already like
Trump it's no one new the reason that he
picked Pence was because Trump is
arguably the least Christian dude out
there on his resume at least so he
needed that Nas white Christian
conservative named Mike Pence to get in
line for that Evangelical vote so now
who's going to be on Trump's short list
I don't see Tu I don't see Tucker run a
poll and see I see Tucker being a beast
I think on a debate stage versus kamla
he would run circles around here I just
don't think he's going to carry
particular an article just came out
Trump is reportedly planning a cabinet
from hell for term two this is
intelligence sir Donald Trump is
reportedly considering a contentious
roster of candid dates for key cabinet
positions in a potential second term
this list include figures like Ohio
Senator JD Vance Arkansas governor Sarah
Huckaby Sanders Arizona's Kerry Lake
South Dakota Governor's chrisy gome
Georgia representative margerie Taylor
green as potential vice president
choices wow those are potential Vice
President Van Sanders Kerry Lake gnome
Taylor and Melania Trump has expressed
interest in Tucker Carlson it could R up
the magga base but would run the risk of
upstaging trump at rallies continues
Trump's intent to reward loyalists who
have backed his claims of election fraud
as evident in
his potential cabinet appointments these
appointments May feature Steven Miller
as attorney general or in a role to
related to immigration enforcement
amongst the names in contention for
cabinet positions are Lee zeldon for
defense secretary Richard grenell for
Director of National intelligence and
Steve Bannon for white house chief of
staff oh my God that'd be crazy but hey
I think the Cary Lake vice president
thing to get the female V too that would
be I mean car Lake would be I think a
great decision I like I like Chrome I
like Sanders a lot you like Sanders
Sarah hucke Sanders oh she's a beast the
problem is you know what like that the
problem with her is she's uh what not
goodlook so I think
that's not a good look tell us okay I'm
just gonna look at her yeah and that's
like a good picture of her somehow Adam
oh my God hold on I'll be under the desk
Optics and how you look actually counts
okay now go to Christy Noom by the way
it's the best picture of Sarah Huck
Sanders I've ever freaking seen ever in
your
life Christin see if you can do a side
by side of these two I mean there's no
need you want to look at that girl every
day or you want to look at that girl
every day what a I think you know where
I vote what about car Lake sex cells bro
would you not be a Car Lake you think
Donald Trump is going to look at Sarah
Huckabee Sanders and be like yeah I uh
not my first p hold on but guess what
that's not what I'm into if he's a he's
loyal to the people that that love him
you can't even front Sarah hakabe
Sanders was in those briefings every
single day in a in a jungle with
everybody from Jim massa's loser ass
screaming at her every freaking 2
minutes it was insane it was insane and
she had his back she never turned that's
your new VP right there I listen by the
way I'm a policy I don't need to look at
her face if she's looking like the one
in the pink right now she could thank
her uh candidacy choices to oek she
looks like she's lost 100 pounds good
for her can't fix an ugly face though
I'm sorry this is just being well listen
anybody that's a loyal she she's loyal
to Trump and she's about that policy
that's great but I'd rather have Christy
know him I Sav the photo yeah I can't
look at that anymore saved the world she
saved our economy too bad she wasn't
more attractive yeah what I mean you
Superwoman yeah you you are you going to
call you know maybe Adam needs to uh
they need to do a part two of the movie
Shallow
how oh and they say shallow Adam and
Tony Robbins comes up and next thing you
know Adam shows up and introduces to a
girl hey this is Mary Dam she's hot what
the hell wrong with you Adam is this guy
okay Adam like oh my God sexy hey sexy
Shadow Adam we can make Adam we can make
up smoo that made Jack Black's career
I'm down so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right
here